hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to you have ten seconds
which is supposedly a very fast pace and
energetic game we're supposed to be
doing these platform things and not die
and you have exactly ten seconds to be
able to do the things that it wants you
to do more it kills you dead and I don't
know how I work under pressure but
obviously you guys know that I don't do
it do well and hopefully it's gonna be
okay I've never played it oh oh look the
threat of death is upon us who the hell
is that okay alright then well so far so
easy there's it oh no I spoke too soon
oh god no oh [ __ ] come on oh come on
piece of [ __ ]
get out of my face there we go there we
go god damnit flipping this upside down
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what Oh certain number of
lives oh one load of [ __ ] I gotta go
oh I only have to live is that such [ __ ]
how are you supposed to be able to do
that oh god that's awful
oh so awful [ __ ] [ __ ] shitty tits shitty
biscuits kak ass okay we'll try this
again geez yeah Oh was I supposed all
that was an extra life oh I should have
picked that up before I thought it was a
threat of death I mean what everything
else is gonna be the threat of death how
am I suppose I supposed to assume that
anything is good in this world
keep-keep okay so far so good I don't
know how I died on this is pretty easy
okay so far so goo Oh what is that all
jump twice nice twice is nice yeah oh it
cuts to silence there okay so I got the
double jump now so hopefully it's gonna
be a bit easier for me but I don't know
about that okay so far so goo oh geez
what is what what happened oh god damn
it [ __ ] you what a sack of asses what a
bag of dicks what a satchel of poop god
damn it my brains not working fast
enough obviously I'm not gonna win this
game if I can't think bad enough
just think about oh [ __ ] you it's going
good [ __ ] [ __ ] a dick [ __ ] suck it
shoulder
[ __ ] [ __ ] alloyed [ __ ] ass and slap
backs and [ __ ] you yep
freakin it there we go yeah the thing is
I'm trying to rush it I'm trying to be
all Oh hip and cool about things that I
should realize how you at least give me
unlimited free lives there that's
awfully nice of it okay we got this oh
[ __ ] this ended stylistic [ __ ] oh
god oh god oh [ __ ] did I [ __ ] up why'd
that happen I don't know okay
Jesus this is gonna get bit too
complicated now I don't need all the
stress blooney the stress okay so far so
easy
fine fine okay
everything's fine Oh what does that mean
what's with the green [ __ ] [ __ ] uh
straight down oh okay there we go
you got it he's good he's good he's good
oh I got goggles underwater that's handy
I guess okay
is this okay fine all right everything's
in a extreme panic Oh God man I used to
play games like this all the time on new
grounds and stuff
Wow [ __ ] off with you come on oh I get
it that reverses the gravity okay
[ __ ] hmm okay so I got it Cosima's
stop being a [ __ ] off ah I wanted ah I
don't want it I don't need it it's a red
herring it's not what I'm supposed to
get it's not important
I don't walk okay we're fine it's a red
herring I don't need it it's oh [ __ ] I
need it
[Music]
for that [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh piece of ass piece of gak the lord of
dick I made that one hundred percent
flappy bird [ __ ] not enough time oh god
the jump it's not responsive enough okay
so we're losing oh geez what is this
what is this I'm jumping oh geez man
jeez ah [ __ ] god damn it we can't we
can't the jump oh the jump is space I
was using the up arrow which was
entirely stupid of me
oh okay that's that's what is much
easier okay that's that's much easier
okay now I think I can actually and then
a pretty sure it's stupid it's stupid I
shouldn't go for it [ __ ] you oh god damn
it I have no lives ah [ __ ] man [ __ ] you
you're sack of [ __ ] [ __ ] is why I can't
play frustrating games they just make me
so may you a different be my blood brush
rub my dr. H
okay easy easy easy easy push it push it
okay that's fine
what I did by [ __ ] em I'm like
spamming it oh come on there we go
okay yeah we got we got we got we got
okay okay zz5 Nevada okay
five in a Bible oh oh [ __ ] I didn't see
where I was okay okay okay okay yeah
there's more Oh be down oh yeah hold it
down okay all right so now I get a
magnum and we got that [ __ ] that's
gonna be Oh cocking up our skis okay so
I now gotta use timing on the magnet for
only ten seconds to be able to do this
[ __ ] okay that's easy enough
whoo I'm getting better at this guys I'm
getting better in better getting better
oh [ __ ] off what happened what happened
oh it's it's in there I didn't see where
[ __ ] rhymin are you serious god damn
it so don't panic
I fall [ __ ] off how what happened
oh god damn it's fine it's fine it's
fine all right
it's fine it's fine okay got that we
were there through there through there
papa Debus Keith okay okay okay oh okay
yes all right I don't even know what
happened but I think I won oh there are
spikes there dad I gotta gotta got it
hey what does that mean oh okay okay
okay okay okay
yeah the red one means that it does not
do the opposite of what it do well that
one was easy are this hard
okay he's easy enough okay easy enough
gave me another one prepare myself I
don't like this oh god oh god oh [ __ ] no
oh god nipple
yeah okay okay okay oh god it's gonna be
a possible leading up to this simple one
last chance I can hear this oh I can do
this [ __ ] you do this to do this to do
this oh oh why is this so difficult this
is simplistic stuff orgies orgy school
board T school
thanks for out in my life counter right
there Scoob oh geez oh geez okay fine
it's fine it's fine
oh Jesus fire oh whoa okay okay
everything's fine whoa geez okay oh boy
oh boy
okay oh geez come on oh [ __ ] man I gotta
go through that all again god damn it
Oh sack of [ __ ]
oh I got the light holy [ __ ] can't
believe I cut the light okay alright
that's why they made this like this part
easier than the other parts like though
the levels leading up to this earth are
not terribly difficult like it if I'm
not a panic mess I can get through them
okay so this is it okay this is it
I got three lives going into this I just
can't waste it whoa here we go what
happened there
three life can't waste them hey I got
robbed it's lost me oh jeez Patsy's
thank you life counter you're a
lifesaver
oh boy
hey yeah you got this
[Music]
I need a keyboard cam to show you guys
that I'm not an idiot
I [ __ ] pressed it goddamn it okay you
got two more chance how you do it on
this one I don't need a second one
[Music]
there's no more right no more no more no
more it's just this new game [ __ ] that
[ __ ] I'm not doing that okay so that is
you have 10 seconds I beat it fair and
square with only moderate amounts of
rage so that was fun
had a great time with that very
stressful Barry down to the wire but I
loved it a lot so hope you guys enjoyed
it too
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always those soon in the next
video
[Music]
something sitter area sobbing such a
baby man